when scholars look back on the 2016
election one of the strangest most
befuddling things though by no means the
strangest or most befuddling things will
be that this guy was the putative
front-runner for the democratic nominee
for the president of the united states
and that's when things got weird
[Music]
michael avenatti the attorney who rose
to fame for his representation of stormy
daniels in lawsuits against president
trump has now been convicted and
sentenced to two and a half years in
prison for attempting to extort nike and
his legal journey is just beginning by
all accounts it looks like he's going to
go to prison for a lot longer before all
of this is done and avedoni's journey
from litigator for the resistance to
disgraced heel of the legal profession
is one of the steepest falls that many
can remember and his legal troubles are
far from over in december he will stand
trial for allegedly stealing 300
thousand dollars from daniels right now
he is currently on trial in los angeles
on charges that he embezzled 10 million
dollars from five clients during jury
selection avenatti fired his lawyer and
got the green light to represent himself
you might think that this is a pretty
standard move but believe me defendants
representing themselves in a criminal
trial is the stuff of bad movies like
this one starring vin diesel with hair
have you had any legal experience
i've been in prison after my life
sometimes i think i had too much legal
experience but you guys this scene
actually happened in real life avenatti
told the judge he was qualified to
represent himself because he had just
participated in his own criminal trial
he told the judge i've made appearances
in less than five maybe two or three
criminal cases your honor i have never
tried a criminal case and then he also
mentioned his participation in the nike
extortion case in the southern district
of new york when the judge asked about
avenatti's participation in criminal
sentencing he again brought up the time
a few weeks ago when he was sentenced to
two and a half years in prison this is
literally a joke from the simpsons and
as for your case don't you worry i've
argued in front of every judge in the
state often as a lawyer
of course legal warnings about the folly
of representing yourself date back all
the way to 1682 there's a reason for the
saying a man who represents himself has
a fool for a client and today we're
going to answer the question just how
foolish is michael avenatti the answer
very it appears to be amateur hour so
who is this guy anyway any discussion of
the avenatti saga has to start with that
question and michael avenatti was not
well known outside of california legal
circles until he burst onto the scene by
suing donald trump on behalf of stormy
daniels avenatti's willingness to opine
on trump made him an attractive guest
for cable news hits in fact he made over
250 television news appearances in less
than two years and then he represented
julie swetnick in a misconduct claim
against supreme court nominee brett
kavanaugh once again putting himself
front and center but not everyone was an
avenatti fan he got into an argument
with michael cohen's lawyer whom he
derided for representing a felon this is
astoundingly bad commentary by avenatti
not to point out the obvious but now he
is such a felon in need of
representation though perhaps his
philosophy is why he wants to represent
himself and avenatti got into frequent
arguments with just about everyone
including well-known former prosecutor
ken white who you might know as pope hat
on twitter and after one of their
twitter arouse avenatti called up white
to yell and curse and proclaim himself
the greatest lawyer who ever lawyered
which of course is incredibly ironic
given his current location
that is not a very smart guy though many
people thought he was a charlatan from
the start millions of people were fooled
his pugnacious tv appearances made him a
popular twitter personality and earned
him speaking engagements all over the
country at one point in 2017 avenatti
announced he was considering running for
president he even visited iowa to
prepare for the presidential primary
michael avenatti looked like a man who
was king of the world flying around the
world on private jets and owning his own
race car company but behind the scenes
avenatti was already cracking let's
start at the beginning of michael
avenatti's legal career in the year 2000
michael avenatti graduated first in his
class from the george washington
university school of law just three
years later gw established the michael j
avenatti award for excellence in
pre-trial and trial advocacy getting an
orb named after you so quickly means two
things one you are making a lot of money
and two you are donating a lot of that
money though avenatti has always had a
gift for scrapping and digging up dirt
before his law career he worked for
former obama chief of staff rahm
emanuel's consulting firm where he
researched the backgrounds of democratic
and republican candidates looking for
the details candidates could use to
bring down their opponents but after law
school avenatti moved to california and
became a well-regarded plaintiff's
attorney in 2008 avenatti won a 32
million judgment against kpmg for
malpractice in 2014 he achieved a 80
million class action settlement with the
los angeles cemetery which dumped the
remains of jewish people into a mass
grave and in 2017 he secured a 454
million judgment against kimberly clark
for defective surgical gowns although
avrahami claims to have won one billion
dollars for his clients many of those
verdicts were substantially reduced on
appeal still by any measure avenatti had
been a very successful trial lawyer this
was enough to get him the attention of
the legal world but outside of it no one
really knew his name in 2015 he had
fewer than 600 twitter followers most of
whom were lawyers and law firms and
despite his professional success
avenatti has never been able to keep his
nose for conflict from interfering with
his business and professional lives he
fought with a former law partner
resulting in an order requiring him to
pay one non-equity partner 15 million
dollars in back pay he then was ordered
to pay 4.85 million dollars for failing
to pay a debt to a former colleague and
eventually his law firm was evicted from
its orange county offices for allegedly
failing to pay months of rent and
avenatti's troubles extended to his
other business connections in 2013
avenatti purchased a seattle coffee
chain called tully's his partner in the
endeavor was mcdreamy himself no not dr
mike original recipe mcdreamy patrick
dempsey dempsey actually sued to back
out of the sale just months later
alleging that avenatti had taken on a
two million dollar loan without telling
him i've already purchased the coffee
company through a larger entity called
global baristas global baristas
struggled to pay suppliers and landlords
and had more than 45 lawsuits filed
against it the company lost a lawsuit
with keurig then a battle with the irs
and then closed down all of the tully
stores while his businesses were beset
by litigation and tax problems avenatti
was maintaining a jet set lifestyle he
owned a 19 million mansion numerous
expensive race cars and two private jets
but then the bad times came they say bad
things happen in threes and that's
certainly been true for michael avenatti
so let's look at the three most recent
cases first is the nike extortion case
avenatti was arrested in march of 2019
minutes after tweeting that he had
scheduled a press conference to quote
disclose a major high school college
basketball scandal perpetrated by nike
that we have uncovered avenatti was
trying to get ahead of the fallout from
federal charges that accused avenatti of
trying to extort nike the charges stem
from a meeting set up by avenatti with
nike that took place on march 19 2019.
the meeting was held under the pretense
that avenatti represented a youth
basketball coach who had information
that nike employees paid the families of
high school athletes abner's client was
gary franklin the coach of a youth
basketball team called california
supreme the team competed in the aau
leagues which are a hotbed of college
basketball recruiting major sneaker
companies like reebok and nike and
adidas all hang around with the players
and college scouts creating an
atmosphere of general shadiness and
coach franklin testified that he was
bullied by nike executives who forced
him to make illicit payments to top high
school basketball players and their
families franklin said that in 2018 the
company ended its sponsorship of the
team and he turned to avenatti for help
during this meeting avenatti demanded
that nike pay franklin 1.5 million
dollars avenatti also wanted nike to pay
him and his co-counsel famed defense
lawyer mark gargos 15 to 25 million
dollars to conduct a internal
investigation on nike's behalf avenatti
who allegedly had a debt of over 11
million dollars at the time said that he
planned an announcement on the eve of
nike's quarterly earnings call and at
the start of the annual ncaa tournament
if they did not agree to the terms of
this agreement avenatti was betting that
nike would rather pay him off rather
than suffer the pr hit which avenatti
predicted would tank nike stock by
billions of dollars as avenatti put it
in their meeting quote the company will
die not die but they are going to incur
cut after cut after cut and that's
what's going to happen as soon as this
thing becomes public unfortunately for
avenatti nike's lawyers who are some of
the best paid and most well-regarded
attorneys in the country were not cowed
and instead called the u.s attorney's
office nike's lawyers asked avenatti to
repeat his offer was he really saying he
should get at least 15 million when his
client was only getting 1.5 million
dollars stupidly not sensing a trap
avenatti said he sure was but i'm not
around so why was this an incredibly
foolish move because the law of
extortion the department of justice has
traditionally been cautious about
charging attorneys with extortion that's
because it's perfectly legal to
negotiate a settlement for a client most
civil cases settle lawyers usually kick
things off with a demand letter followed
by negotiations and sometimes mediation
it's legal to make demands in the
context of negotiations even crazy
demands for lots of money so when do a
lawyer's demands become extortion well
federal extortion is covered by the
hobbes act and this is a law that makes
extortion in blackmail illegal and the
hobbes act defines extortion as quote
the obtaining of property from another
with his consent induced by wrongful use
of actual or threatened force violence
or fear under color of official right
now the line between extortion and legal
settlement negotiations is not well
demarcated a threat of litigation is
generally not considered criminal this
is true even if the lawyer's threats to
sue are supported by false testimony or
fabricated evidence federal courts have
held that if a lawsuit is not pursued
exclusively by lawful methods threat of
litigation might constitute extortion
and the courts look at many factors
including whether an entity like nike
was more afraid that his actual illegal
conduct would be exposed or more afraid
of publicity from illegitimate threats
and if that sounds murky to you that's
because it really is lawyers have a
professional responsibility to zealously
represent their clients and avenatti
argued that he was doing just that
against a company that had committed
wrongdoing however if a lawyer starts to
stray from their responsibility to their
clients that's a huge red flag and this
is where avenatti ran into trouble when
a lawyer uses methods like publicity
grossly exaggerated demands and false
information a negotiation can turn into
an illegal shakedown and remember
avenatti wasn't asking nike to pay the
fees franklin incurred he wanted nike to
pay him and garegos millions of dollars
to act as internal investigators federal
prosecutors said avenatti took advantage
of franklin hoping to use his client to
pay off his massive personal debt coach
franklin said he wanted his team back
and two nike executives fired but
avenatti ignored what his client
actually wanted instead avidani started
asking nike to pay him personally and on
top of that he apparently didn't
disclose these payment demands to
franklin the coach also said he knew
nothing about avenatti's plan to hold a
press conference and this is of course
strikingly similar to how avenatti
allegedly handled litigation with
daniels ignoring her stated goals while
pursuing his own the jury obviously was
swayed by the fbi recordings where
avenatti pressured nike to agree to his
terms or suffer the consequences and if
you don't want to do that we're done
i'm not around with this and i'm not
continuing to play games
you guys know enough now to know you got
a serious problem and it's worth more in
exposure to me to just blow the lid on
this thing a few million dollars doesn't
move the needle for me i'm just being
really frank with you obviously the
emphasis of the phone calls appeared to
be what was good for avenatti personally
rather than what was right for his
client and the jury probably also
considered avanade's threat to take 10
billion off of nike's market cap by
disclosing franklin's allegations this
was construed as a grossly exaggerated
economic threat and at the conclusion of
the three-week trial of verdict by a
unanimous jury found michael avenatti
guilty on all counts the jury didn't buy
the defense's closing argument that
quote in the words of nike itself he
went in there to just do it for his
client at avenatti's sentencing he
appeared tearful and apologetic he said
quote i and i alone have destroyed my
career my relationships and my life and
he continued quote your honor i've
learned that all the fame notoriety and
money in the world is meaningless tv and
twitter your honor mean nothing amen to
that still this tactic was probably a
good one he seemed to be getting
reasonably good legal advice because the
sentence that he ultimately got was
significantly lower than what the
prosecutors wanted him to get the judge
sentenced him to two and a half years in
prison and the judge cited two things
for the downward departure from the
guidelines the horrible conditions in
the manhattan jail where avenatti spent
more than 100 days and the absence of
mark gyracos prosecutors declined to
charge gyrgos even though he attended
all the meetings with avenatti and
played good comp to avenatti's bad cop
the judge called gyragos quote a central
figure in the criminal conduct the judge
listened to the avenatti tapes and
concluded garagos's conduct simply
wasn't distinguishable from avenatti and
that is an interesting question but that
is just the tip of the avenatti iceberg
because he faces continued legal
jeopardy in california where he used to
primarily practice aphrodite is now on
trial for defrauding clients and
absconding with payments to them
specifically a federal ground jury
indicted avenatti on 36 counts of fraud
perjury failure to pay taxes
embezzlement and other financial crimes
the indictment alleges that avenatti
stole several million dollars from five
clients and used a variety of shell
companies and bank accounts to cover up
his crimes and the crimes range from
stealing from a mentally ill paraplegic
on disability who won a 4 million
settlement in a suit against los angeles
county to a 2.5 million settlement that
was primarily used for the purchase of a
private jet
allegedly now avenatti is now acting as
his own lawyer in these criminal cases
meaning that he is literally going to
cross-examine former clients who now
accuse him of stealing from them for
example on the first day of trial
avenatti confronted jeffrey johnson who
avedani represented in a lawsuit over
injuries he sustained while jumping from
an elevated floor in a los angeles jail
johnson tried to kill himself twice
after bullying in attacks by inmates and
corrections officers avenue negotiated a
4 million settlement with los angeles
county but the money was put in a
medical trust that avenatti controlled
johnson accused avenatti of draining
nearly all of the 4 million dollars in
settlements while paying johnson roughly
nineteen hundred dollars a month to lull
him into thinking his money was safe
though perversely avenatti's
cross-examination of johnson gives us a
good window on what made him a good
trial lawyer in the first place avenatti
got johnson to admit that he hired
avenatti to get him out of jail by any
means necessary and that avenatti
delivered johnson admitted that avenatti
got him released to a medical center and
then avenatti paid the bill for all of
it johnson admits that the care center
cost several thousand dollars a month
and then avenatti paid for that as well
and all this sounds like avenatti did
real work on the case and he probably
did but as the prosecution established
on direct examination avenatti asked
johnson to sign a peculiar document
attesting to his ethics and great work
as a lawyer the document says avenatti
is quote an exceptional honest and
ethical attorney and i feel fortunate to
have had him represent me there's just
one giant problem with this attestation
avenatti had been charged with stealing
johnson's settlement the day before he
asked johnson to sign the document and
johnson apparently didn't know that
avenatti had been accused of embezzling
the funds at any rate if avenatti is
convicted of all of the charges in the
california indictment avenatti could
face many more years in prison on top of
the two and a half years he already got
from the new york prosecutors which
brings us to the stormy daniels case
later this year avenatti will stand
trial yet a third time bringing his time
in the public eye full circle avenue
will have to defend himself against
charges of wire fraud and aggravated
identity theft in the case involving
stormy daniels though ironically by this
time he'll have quite a lot of
experience as a criminal defense
attorney meaning he might actually know
what he's doing this time around
avenatti is accused of using
misrepresentations in a fraudulent
document reporting to bear the name of
stormy daniels and her own signature to
convince her literary agent to send him
the money the agent owed daniels for a
book advance once avenatti fraudulently
obtained the money he allegedly used it
to pay for typical attorney expenses
such as restaurants meal delivery
services and car payments on his ferrari
when daniels began to question where her
money was avenatti lied that he was
still trying to obtain it from the
publisher and then when he finally paid
her he did so by improperly diverting
funds from another source this is the
same kind of alleged conduct that
avenatti pulled with patrick dempsey and
the california clients if avenatti isn't
disbarred as a result of the prior two
cases if he's found guilty in this
particular case he absolutely will be
disbarred from ever practicing law again
and avenatti potentially faces a maximum
of 20 years for the wire fraud case in
addition to a mandatory two-year prison
sentence for the aggravated identity
theft charge oh and of course it won't
surprise you to learn that avenatti
wasn't shooting straight with the irs
either during the commission of all of
these alleged crimes avenatti had a
four-year streak where he did not file
personal income tax returns and three of
those years he did not file tax returns
for both of his law firms in addition he
allegedly lied to the irs about
pocketing nearly 2.4 million dollars in
taxes withheld from the paychecks of
employees of global baristas us which
operated the now defunct tully's coffee
stores and in the california case the
jury's already heard testimony from
three other former clients avenatti
allegedly stiffed youtuber michelle phan
a makeup artist out of at least four
million dollars avenatti's former
paralegal testified that she was
instructed to give fan the run around on
an 8 million wire transfer of funds that
belonged to fan eventually avenatti told
the paralegal to send a partial payment
of 4 million dollars but affidavit
allegedly embezzled the other 4 million
dollars additionally gregory bareilles
alleges that avignoni ran his law firm
like a ponzi scheme accusing him of
stealing settlement funds and then
trying to lend him the funds at a 10
interest rate avenatti handled
litigation for barela securing him a
settlement of over two million dollars
but in january 2018 a third party
started paying funds into a client trust
fund managed by avenatti for him to pass
on to barilla but instead of doing so
avenatti allegedly told barela that the
third party never paid the settlement
money when barela hired new lawyers to
get the settlement funds the third party
told him that they had already paid
money to avenatti alexis gardner hired
avenatti to represent her in a lawsuit
against her ex-boyfriend nba basketball
player hassan whiteside avenatti
negotiated settlement of around three
million dollars in early 2017. he told
gardner that the money would be doled
out in monthly increments but during
2018 the monthly payment stopped
avenatti assured garner that he was
hounding whiteside every week about
missing payments however prosecutors say
that in reality whiteside's financial
team had already paid avenatti a lump
sum of 2.7 million dollars a year
earlier they allege that avenatti spent
the money on private airplanes and other
luxuries if these allegations are true
avenatti has committed fraud and broken
many of the rules of professional
contact for lawyers when a lawyer
receives money meant for a client the
lawyer doesn't own that money that's
common sense the lawyer has to keep that
in trust aba model rule 1.5 covers this
exact scenario quote a lawyer shall hold
property of clients or third persons
that is in a lawyer's possession in
connection with a representation
separate from the lawyer's own property
funds shall be kept in a separate
account maintained in the state where
the lawyer's office is situated or
elsewhere with the consent of the client
or third person although the rules of
professional conduct are not criminal
laws when lawyers misuse client funds
criminal charges may follow if those
actions rise to the level of criminal
conduct and
here if these allegations are true that
standard is definitely met prosecutors
accused avenatti of lying to gardner and
varela about the structure of their
payments the model rules cover this as
well upon receiving funds or other
property in which a client or the person
has an interest a lawyer shall promptly
notify the client or third person which
avenatti allegedly did not do the bottom
line here is that avedon is going to
prison for a very long time regardless
of the outcome of these california cases
so we'll definitely need some new
hobbies to keep him occupied he'd really
benefit from mary andrew's skillshare
class drawing his self-discovery five
ways to start because avenatti's gonna
have a ton of time for painting where
he's going or he could use emma gannon's
class finding fulfillment using pivots
to power your creative career because
michael avenatti is going to have to
pivot hard away from you know actually
being a lawyer skillshare today's
sponsor has classes on almost everything
from video to music to business and
entrepreneurship it's one of the world's
largest online learning communities with
tens of thousands of classes on
absolutely everything so it's the best
place for a former lawyer to get a new
start so if you'd like to try out
skillshare the first 1000 legal eagles
to use my link below will get a free
trial of skillshare premium and for
limited time this trial is for an entire
month not just 14 days as usual and
after that trial and skillshare is still
way more affordable than most online
learning platforms so just click on this
link that's on screen right now to get a
free trial of skillshare plus clicking
on this link really helps out this
channel
and while you're there click on this
other link for all my other real law
reviews or i'll see you in court